these were your morning announcements
and as always I'm Rachel Richards I'm
Rachel Nelson and together we're the
Rachel's the Rachel's are your typical
teen Queens how many followers do you
know I don't know I mean you're not even
that photogenic anyway so I would do
care but when one starts to outshine the
other are you doing this work Nelson
thanks things are about to turn ugly do
you think you can just cut me out I made
you wear the Rachel's well maybe I don't
want to be the Rachel's anymore Rachel
Nelson has fallen to her death from the
roof of this complex Rachel Richards was
also present at this party the two girls
were known as social media starlets I am
the star now with all eyes on Rachel
she is creating her own grieving vestrum
reality show and old rival will see
through the lies Akutan she was
determined what did she to say and stop
Rachel for getting the attention she
desires what if we don't let her get
away with it what if we make Rachel most
of the most popular girl in school again
it's at the yearbook I think I'll see
you there and
me and Rachel will do whatever it takes
to stay in the spotlight I'm giving this
place what it needs needs a little drama
a little mystery plus America loves a
tragedy
Marvis to entertainment presents Caitlyn
Carver medicine Iseman Austin Caldwell
with Daniela Bobadilla you still want
people to believe that she jumped tell
the truth Rachel Nelson didn't jump I
pushed her and she deserved it some
girls will do anything to be remembered
nobody ever remembers the victim but
everyone always remembers the villain
[Music]
you
you